在就想免费，
你，
你真金白银让他给你还20万债试试，
你让他给你还30万债试你今天晚上就测试，
你说我欠30万，
你能给我还吗？
你看他还不还，
他要还的话你行中那中你还一个，
他说不还的话，
你就别想那个，
我也是在想要不要分的问题，
结婚有12年了，
现在两个孩子嘛，
俩孩子四年级一到五年级，
很大的是男孩儿，
小的是姑娘，
我来问你吧，
男的是干什么工作呀？
他在电视台收入怎么样啊，
月经在6000左右啊，
那你是干什么工作呀？
我工作相对于没有那么稳定，
现在是在做直播，
我计划的话再去找一份工作，
带着做业务的，
加上直播，
我目前我是这样规划的，
做两份工作，
这俩孩子现在谁管的比较多一点呀，
我管的多一点，
因为他那个工作他不是说正常的，
有时候他可能上早班，
有时候可能上晚班，
就这样子的，
那有人帮衬你吗？
没有你一个人管小孩子，
你还得挣钱，
那挺辛苦呀，
现在孩子大了嘛，
就是还好吧，
他们自己也都基本上可以完成，
我就稍微督促一下，
检查一下，
现在俩人经济条件怎么样啊，
家里现在就是这个问题比较严重，
是因为欠债的问题吗？
对谁欠债了，
为啥欠他债啊，
本来收入一直都不是很高，
之前的话一直在租房子，
后来买房子，
结婚之前他有一套房子，
比较偏僻的地方有一套，
然后他自己付的首付，
然后说婚后的话我们一起还了房贷，
那套房子因为我们都不在工作的地方，
拖了几年卖了。
还掉贷款，
剩下15万，
这个首付不是不够嘛，
我就找我亲戚，
我妈还，
我同学，
我又借了10万，
零零散散的25万吧，
当时他的征信有问题，
所以说呢，
以我一个人的名义贷的款，
后来还贷的话，
他也没给我钱，
我就一直我自己还，
装修的时候也没钱，
也是用我的名义贷的款，
贷了15万，
加上别了利息一起3万进去了，
这些钱全部都是我还的，
你总共还了多少房贷啊，
装修贷总共还了多少？
能租贷就是15万加3万的利息，
这是18万，
房贷的话就是因为我信用卡，
就是平时就没钱用的时候，
我都是用信用卡周转的啊，
因为我额度还可以，
我把里面钱全部弄出来了，
又还了5万房贷进去，
房贷的本金我是还了92000，
利息的话是113000，
合起来的话就是20.5万，
房子登记在谁的名下，
你名下对不对，
跑一个人名下，
对，
那你现在就是心里委屈的点，
你在你什么，
平时在日常生活当中，
他除了生活上一些费用，
他会买一些东西，
孩子的赌托费，
晚托费，
两个孩子一起一个月的是800块钱，
最开始的话也是我在出，
后来是我逼着他出，
现在是他在出，
日常一些开销他在出，
是他的所有的开销都是加在我身上，
那你现在这个贷款一个月要还多少啊？
账面上来看，
除了房贷还有39万，
信用卡的话，
现在账面上是50，
利息刨掉的话大概是在42个，
42个我手上预留下来的。
有十个，
那这个房子现在值多少钱呀？
房子现在可能就60万左右吧，
那你现在想问我啥问题呀？
大部分负债都在我名下，
我跟他要，
他也没有给我的，
包括这些贷款什么的，
全部都是我要承担。
我现在想问的就是他明天签的可能有十几个，
比我少很多，
我想跟他分开，
我觉得分开的话，
可能我还有机会再遇到一个吧，
那也没有人接盘呀，
现在人多金啊，
一人一看，
你身上背那么多债，
谁愿意接盘啊，
你还俩孩子，
谁愿意接这个盘呢？
实话实啊，
姐妹啊，
就是咱俩就当老姐妹，
实打实的聊天，
咱如果说不是有那种绝世的容颜，
不是有那种说当王妃的气质，
不是有那种身材特别妖娆，
就特别有手腕儿，
你说咱自己欠一屁股债，
完了之后咱拖俩孩子，
你说找谁接盘，
这个问题我也考虑过，
就是现在嘛，
有这么个人吧，
他现在就想免费是你，
你真金白银让他给你还20万债试试，
你让他给你还3万债试你今天晚上去测试，
你说我欠30万，
你能给我还吗？
你看他还不还，
他还的话你行，
分分钟你换一个，
他说不还的话，
你就别别想那个，
你就说我现在欠30万，
你能给我还吗？
今天晚上去测试，
问这个我之前问过的，
他说没有问题，
转给我呀，
钱给我呀，
别扯那个，
确实这么个事儿，
但是现在让别人攒也不合适，
怎么不合适呢？
你不是喜欢我吗？
你不是愿意接盘吗？
你不是爱我吗？
你不是表达真心吗？
表达忠心吗？
我现在面对这么大的困难，
我都要。
抑郁了，
我逼了，
这个债我都还不了，
我那么难过，
你能忍心吗？
你不是爱我吗？
我跟你说别扯那个，
他是不见兔子不发音，
你不给他生孩子，
他能给你30万，
你再生孩子，
你自己有这点本事，
我不信他能给你30万，
现在你去测试，
你就说晚上都睡不着觉啊，
我欠这么多钱呢，
我必须要把这个钱还上才行啊，
你今天晚上你让他转试试你就知道了，
就算没有这么个人，
我现在跟他，
我就是看不到希望，
你这个马，
咱话说回来啊，
我这话是马后炮，
放屁的话，
就你俩这条件还生二胎，
就你俩这条件还给着脚尖去买房子去装修，
你俩这心里没点数吗？
你自己把自己拖成这样的，
是的，
那没事儿啊，
反正我人活着呀，
我还嫌健康啊，
我现债是欠债啊，
但我有俩快乐的健康的孩子呀，
总了算哪呗，
能还还不能还，
房子一卖，
把债空窿一抵，
我这话我这么说明白好不好？
嗯，
就你俩这经济条件的话，
就俩人再相爱，
那日子也过不好啊，
过不好才正常啊，
就你俩没有个计划，
踮着脚尖去装修，
踮着脚尖去买房，
踮着脚尖生孩子，
在这种土壤下是不可能培养出来两个人感情很好的，
不可能的，
你俩感情不好才正常，
现在就是不正常啊，
你要说你要找外面那男的的话，
那你就先让她给你30万，
你再离这个婚，
我真的当你亲姐妹啊，
你先让她给你30万，
你再考虑离这个婚，
不然的话都好的，
你就能试出真心是什么样的啊，
如果要分的话，
这房子什么？
合的一人一半啊，
但是装修的，
首付的，
包括房贷利息大部分都是我出的，
那法律上你挣的也是夫妻共同财产啊，
你这头你还出轨了，
你还没有任何别人的把柄，
你但凡有他的把柄，
你也能多分点啊，
是吧，
你连他的把柄都没有，
关键是你这头你还出轨，
只能一人一半这么分啊，
但是如果说他愿意多分给你也是他的事儿，
他没发现是他的事儿啊。
嗯，
可怜孩子呀，
俩孩子多好啊，
健健康康的，
一个四年级，
一个五年级，
就是到了不用太管的年纪了，
见风就长的年纪了，
可怜的孩子，
我感觉这事儿啊，
别想着别人给我解套，
你就想吧，
你要是个男的，
你真心愿意来帮你解这个套吗？
拉出俩孩子欠那么一屁股的债，
你要是个男的，
你真心愿意吗？
换位思考一下，
我也有这样的疑惑，
所以现在那些骗你要的男的，
说出来的承诺，
你没有兑现的都当放屁，
你不要轻信，
不要现在就相信他，
哎呀，
视如己出，
帮你还债是一是承担，
之前我已经有了跟他想要离的这个想法，
后来才有这么个人，
并不是说有了这个人我才要跟他离，
是这个逻辑，
反正就外面这个男的的话，
你把希望寄托在别人身上都会落空的。
姐妹，
我知道龙慧姐你的意思，
我的真实想法就是，
如果说没有这个人，
我也是想离了，
你离完了也解决不了债务的问题啊，
你绑着这个男的过，
他好。
得一个月七八千块钱，
6000块钱，
他是每个月有活钱啊，
他知道开车要几百块钱都是我错，
娃子需要补钙牙交的什么费用全都是我错，
他没有行，
那我不劝你了啊，
你别哭啊，
我不劝你了，
那我尊重你，
还是得听我的，
这外面这男的他真金白银给你钱，
这外面这男的真金白银给你转账，
你就信他的话，
他但凡不是真金白银给你钱给你转账的话，
你别信他的话，
不然的话到时候你又失望又落空好不好，
那就这把没有别的了，
好，
那就这样啊，
拜拜，
记得点赞关注哦。